we bring anion eagle who just call
Jaguars bills with mike Mayock on
Westwood one hi oh yeah
how are you sir full I had the full
Mayock effect he had he had red meat the
night before the end that is a rarity he
may go for red beet so that just showed
you the kind of ferocious mentality he
had for the playoff weekend in Jackson
now I listen to much of the game with
you and and Mike but for those who might
not have heard it how does one describe
17 punts how does one paint that word
picture ion yes yes it takes a creative
soul to attack that from a play-by-play
perspective you know what my expectation
level going in was that we were not
going to have much offense so I wasn't
really that shocked at the final score
at the way the game turned out and how
the game played out buffalo hung in
there Bill's made enough plays to be in
it down the stretch it was a shame that
Tyrod Taylor went down with the injuries
would have been exciting to see a couple
of plays I thought Peterman might be
able to carve himself into Buffalo lore
had that shot was he had that shot his
first net was fourth down and he
converted it yep kept it alive man that
was it yeah but ultimately you're
talking about a prime time defense with
Jacksonville Buffalo had a tough time
generate offense to begin with going
again to that D and that's really to me
the the interesting narrative to this
game with Pittsburgh at Jacksonville can
hang if they can make it intriguing in
the fourth quarter the defense is going
to have to create some things on their
own because they just can't score with
this Steeler squad they can't they're
not equipped to do that on offense as
good as four net was in the first half
of the year there has been a drop off
and they've lean more on bortles the
problem was we saw some of the old
bortles last week compared to the
portals that we had seen from week 10 to
week 15 and they're hoping maybe he can
conjure up some of the memories from
late in the season and not the playoff
game against Buffalo well I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask you this question that a lot
of people are asking
and I'm going to infuse it with the
caveat that you are a lead-pipe wielding
professional who calls multiple sports
no seriously I'm being I am being
serious here you are okay okay and you
call football basketball you call
multiple sports you've been around
professional athletes of all shapes and
sizes so you know how difficult it is to
reach the pinnacle of the NFL but with
the play calling that we saw do you
think and and at times where where
Jacksonville just flat out just took the
ball out of bortles hands do you think
Blake bortles was playing scared on
Sunday I Neagle yeah I think in the
context of that description yes I
believe that bortles didn't want to make
a big mistake it probably was pounded
into his mind over and over again do not
turn the ball over do not hand them a
gift and the reality is they won because
of that he did just enough with his legs
that's not going to work against that
mentality which was fine get you a
playoff win and get you to the next step
the bigger picture for Jacksonville is
not even just this week rich it's down
the road when they have to make large
decisions about their roster and whether
or not Blake bortles is going to be back
at 19.1 million dollars next year these
are the kinds of games that determine
your fate and look you've been around us
a long time as have I when you're picked
third overall in the draft when you're
paid a ton of money there is a certain
expectation level that comes with that
and because of it
that's why bortles gets a lot of the
criticism that he gets and also because
he hasn't produced consistently in the
passing it we just haven't seen enough
consistent production there have been
flashes there have been moments but if
you look at him and the totality of who
he is he's not obviously in that upper
echelon of quarterbacks he's he's in the
mid to late area of assessing cubies
because he just hasn't been able to do
it you're in a knee wraps he doesn't
throw the ball with confidence yet the
dropping the shotgun snap picking it up
and running for the first down that by
the way the worst Statue of Liberty play
I've ever seen
that's just not gonna cut it against the
Pittsburgh Steelers this no it's just
it's not and it's interesting ly enough
when he was drafted third overall at the
combine that year the talk was he could
be the next Ben Roethlisberger saw his
arm legs and Big Ben as we recall was
they went to the the Bill Cowher school
of game management as he took the
Steelers to their first Super Bowl win
under Cour that year and good lord of
all the players that they're taking on
right now I just don't I don't see it
what what do you think the Steelers team
will look like going into this game
alright
well certainly the the first games come
up a lot and we're responsible for that
but they're responsible for that they
brought it up right away the media is
gonna hearken back to it but waffles
Berger himself admitted to the fact that
he wanted Jacksonville again that was an
embarrassing day for him five
interceptions that was if you remember
after the game where he in my mind
sarcastically said maybe I just don't
have it anymore right and everybody took
that and ran with it
Roethlisberger might be thinking about
this is it it's over no it's not it's
not over Roethlisberger
you make a great point when he came into
the league there were those thoughts
that he was unrefined that he wasn't a
polished thrower that it this would have
to develop well it did develop he's
become one of the best cubies in the NFL
he's a Hall of Fame player bortles has
not been able to make that turn in his
career the hitch that he still has
inconsistency in his mechanics
Roethlisberger sorted all of that out
and I think there is a real sense of
trying to reverse the conversation from
what happened earlier in the year this
is just a better Pittsburgh team than
they were in week five to Jay Smith
Shuster wasn't a part of it yet I think
defensively they've gained some steam
the loss of Ryan shazier
is huge we know how immense that is the
heart and soul of that defense but
offensively they are now the unit that I
thought they were going to be going into
the year took a while but they're there
now I an eagle calling Jaguar Steelers
on CB
Sunday morning joining me here on the
show any word on Artie Burns that you
you might have heard he left practice
yesterday any first blog you're not on
the ground yet in Pittsburgh correct I
know
the Steelers tomorrow meeting with the
Jaguars on Saturday obviously we'll try
to get a little more insight when we sit
down okay the latest I had heard
probably the same that you had heard the
initial feeling was worse than it turned
out to be and how the hope is they might
be able to to get him ready to go for
Sunday now when you you sit down with
the Jaguars and Marrone you show up five
minutes earlier right Oh correct yes I'm
on I'm a twelve minutes early kind of
guy I want to take that number and I
want to I want to make it even more
impressive I'm twelve minutes early what
about bounce what off outs is he about
yeah even with a gold jacket guy you
think maybe he'd have little leeway
he's like a nine minutes early guy yah
what is the big show that we're gonna
promote on CBS on Sunday what's the
what's the number one comedy in America
right now I on what's what's the number
one drama that's going to be a power
circuit when when I when you read that
card and you nail it by the way you
stick the land
yeah angry does like you do a lot the
blue cards I haven't seen the preview
yet I would say young Sheldon it's got
to get a major run a major run week okay
okay can you work you know give too much
away can you work you know you can you
work in a Rich Eisen show promo just
sneak it in there what do you think here
we go working working in between young
and well 2 broke girls is done right
okay they're broke they're just you know
rich you can watch it any day of the
week in Sri Lanka okay so in between
young Sheldon's a doctor show on CBS and
just and and the good doctor right is
the good doctor or CBS so that's I think
that's fine I don't believe so
okay so no no how just let's just go
easy guys come on
two and a Half Men oh that's done - I'm
sorry they're done - oh and Oh swap okay
shemar Moore SWAT young Sheldon working
working the Rich Eisen show where
anything can happen and it's one of my
favorite shows just work that in there
and it's a matter could you play the
theme so you can work on it
Jumana I'm good coming up
young Sheldon and one of my favorite
shows on television and radio the Rich
Eisen show only see what do you think
quickly segue to swap so so Moonves
doesn't know I didn't work you're more
and more in
how to look at you like what the hell is
happening anyway but how many how many
of those you get from Mayock I get one
of those every five minutes when I saw
like that I got like I honestly I got
one last week where I thought that it
might get physical he gave me like
really is that what you're saying cuz we
talked about cap capping there was a
backup lineman in the game uh-huh
and I said that would be as if your name
was Mike Mike Mike we're on our 17th
punt if I have to if I have to use the
word high-arcing parabola to describe
that one more time you know call me a
dude yes and then early fourth I got a
second dude I got double duty on the
business end of a double dude from my
guy and I look forward to the call man I
always enjoy our chats on this show
thanks for calling in brother me too
right yeah really thank you got it
that's Iron Eagle the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience